[Music]
America schools have been caught up in
testing mania for well most of the 21st
century it's long past time that we
focused on a healthier vision of good
schooling not just reading in math but
also character responsibilities good
citizenship the push for social and
emotional learning or SEL can help with
all of this that's why I was pleased to
see the influential Aspen Institute
recently released a consensus report
from its national panel on SEL I was
less pleased to see that the consensus
was mostly banality and downright
disappointed to see it filled with the
ideological gobbledygook of education
school progressivism talk of character
and personal responsibility with
conspicuous in its absence we all want
schools to be more focused on character
and all the needs of our kids but real
consensus will require honoring
traditional values not just progressive
enthusiasms if SEL winds up hijacked by
well-meaning ideologues a promising
cause will morph into a divisive
educational culture war what do you
think about social and emotional
learning let us know in your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI